[Music]
for our three meals series this morning
we're going to take you to Texas to hear
what's on voters minds there major
Garrett traveled across the Lone Star
State in search of good food good
conversation always nice when that
happens so major this is what I'm
hearing that you visited Stafford
Midland and garland for breakfast lunch
and dinner I like that what did voters
have to say to you well Gail good
morning in Texas impeachment came up
frequently sometimes we raised it
sometimes voters brought it up
spontaneously overall most voters were
fatigued by it all but as you will see
those paying close attention defied
party stereotypes we started our journey
in a diverse area outside of Houston
eggs hash browns and pancakes dance
across the griddle at the Avalon diner
in Stafford Texas cotton was a dentist
his wife Janine a speech therapist the
economy's going really well I think
overall we're safe as a country
everything's went pretty well the sign
outside backs that up the Avalon's owner
told us she's lost workers to better
jobs elsewhere Scott did not vote for
mr. Trump in 2016 but will this year
Janine was with the president from the
beginning more conservative values tend
to go more with that person just across
from Scott and Jeanine we met Bernard
and Sharon Menor both work in health
care I feel mystified when I'm listening
to what Donald Trump has to say how
frequently now or during the Trump
presidency have you found yourself
shaking your head every day
said that we needed a change you know
they wanted to make a miracle great
again
you know I'm wondering those same people
do they think he has made America great
again
then it was on to lunch and conservative
Midland a boom town in West Texas where
oil and natural gas production runs
around the clock and Mac's barbecue a
local favorite the brisket is
slow-cooked Outback for 18 hours
customers start arriving for lunch about
11:00 Kyle Davis his brother Jake and
their business partner Tom hall run a
construction and drilling company Kyle
and Jake support President Trump and
expect him to be reelected I don't like
all the nonsense that comes with him but
yeah his his policy has been spot-on I
really don't I kind of feel like he
divided our country we asked both about
impeachment Kyle's answer surprised us
wasn't an impeachable offense yeah it
sounds like it probably was Jake took
the long view I'm sure at some point
every president could have been a Beach
Tom calls himself a New England
Republican and considers mr. Trump a
failure the economy has been propped up
with record levels of deficit spending
and he picks fights that he doesn't know
how to get out of we also met Alison
Louetta Laura or Tagen and Jennifer
Reyes Alison works in insurance Laura
and Jennifer are data specialists for
drilling companies he makes some times
especially being Hispanic so it's been a
community we feel targeted do you feel
lumped in or somehow demonized in a way
I guess I mean moments like that
shouldn't be made by somebody
power and authority you know Texas is a
really big place ten European countries
could fit inside Texas with room to
spare the statues are really big in
Texas just check with Sam Houston father
of Texas dinner took us to the Flying
Saucer pub in Garland a politically
moderate area in northeast of Dallas
Rita ducek and her husband al you did I
did because I thought we need somebody
that's not a politician well then will
you vote for him again I'm a registered
Republican but I don't like extremism on
either side just across the way we met
David Lindsey who owns a construction
firm the economy is calling inside the
company you give anyone in the political
world credit for that I will follow me
give we raised the president's volatile
style you ever wish you would tone it
down
oh yeah I think somebody should hide his
cellphone on blake Hammerton and Daniel
Torres both opposed mr. Trump in 2016
and will vote in the March 3rd Texas
Democratic primary the young girl will
come out this year yeah when you think
about the Democrats what are your
thoughts stop making everything a battle
to the end the Democrats are exhausting
themselves and exhausting the public
sound like they're exhausting you yes
we asked everyone if they had seen or
remembered Mike Bloomberg TV ad all but
two had and interestingly Democrats said
they were keeping an open mind for Texas
is Super Tuesday primary and Trump
supporters said they thought Bloomberg
might give the president the toughest
challenge Anthony I'll take this because
I got a question here for the manager
well first of all I mean how does he get
so many food assignments you're the host
of the takeout which is built around
meals and now you get three dishes for
this assignment but I had a question my
participant preparation okay it's all
about prepper and execution and
seniority I think is well Bernie Sanders
is surging in early states one week
ahead until the Iowa caucuses if he
survives Iowa and wins in New Hampshire
whatever is down there in Texas saying
about him and the rest of the Democratic
field
the fascinating thing we found as we
kept asking about impressions for
Democrats for Iowa New Hampshire did we
find hard-core Bernie supporters or
Elizabeth Warren supporters or Joe Biden
supporters flat line across the board
Texas Democrats and we talked to many
are waiting for Iowa New Hampshire South
Carolina Nevada to sort this out but the
one person they were keeping in mind
because he's on TV so frequently in
Texas Mike Bloomberg that's his strategy
I'm not saying it's gonna work but it
left an impression with those voters
while others who are fighting it out in
Iowa New Hampshire elsewhere have yet to
make an impression at least in Texas
he's counting on it to work Mike
Bloomberg his strategy and it sounds
like they're at least open to it major
that's what something very much of one
other thing when we asked people what
they thought about the November election
their emotions they said two words
anticipation and dread those are kind of
conflicting lines that says everything
all right major thank you